people will descend on downtown las
vegas for the life is beautiful music
festival it's a three-day event and it
will have strict health protocols kate
houston is live near fremont and carson
where the festival will operate a pop-up
rapid testing center kate
yes well for unvaccinated or partially
vaccinated attendees they will need a
negative covid19 test before they can go
in they can come here tomorrow starting
at 9 a.m they can get a 15 minute rapid
test at a discounted price attendees
tell me these measures are added
reassurance that they'll be safe this
weekend
[Music]
the sold out festival will span 18
blocks within the heart of downtown las
vegas
attendees will need to show proof of
full vaccination or a negative test the
clear app is the fastest way to show
vaccination status at the event you can
also get in by showing your vaccination
card or a copy of it even a photo the
same goes for proof of a negative test
i'm very supportive and i'm very
thankful that life is beautiful is
taking those protocols in order for us
to have fun and be able to go back to
normal if you're making the decision to
go into crowds of tens of thousands of
people to go see a concert you kind of
know what you're signing up for so
at that point you're taking the risk in
your own hands and obviously they have
some extra protocols in place a kova 19
test has to be taken within 72 hours of
each day of attendance three day ticket
holders can get tested on or after
thursday for their negative result to
cover all three festival days at home
tests are not accepted
well back out here live you can book an
appointment until 6 p.m tonight or you
can just walk up to this white tent here
behind me and get your 15-minute rapid
test